let's talk about a the decade-long
Republican plan to sabotage democracy we
talk about voter suppression often and
when we talk about it we usually cover
it at the micro level so like voter ID
voter purges closed polling places
limiting voting hours but voter
suppression is just one part of the
Republican plan to sabotage democracy
there's a really good documentary out
called rigged the voter suppression
playbook it's comprehensive it shows you
the insidious nature of this very
well-crafted plan that works against
democracy on many levels laws preventing
previously convicted felons from voting
that's a part of it
the stuff we've talked about over the
last couple of weeks months and years
voter ID limiting voting hours all of
that stuff that's an element of it
ending same-day registration in as many
places as they've been able to end it
that's a piece of it
but there are other less obvious
elements the fight against public
transit even though it can be said that
it's for financial reasons or whatever
else it also makes it tougher for people
to get to the polls when you have weak
or non-existent public transit this all
is happening in concert with giving the
rich and corporations more power money
is speech unlimited campaign spending
allowing some types of campaign
contributions to be made anonymous when
you go through super PACs what does this
all do it takes the power away from the
commoners from the poor people from
non-white people whatever however you
want to slice and dice it and it gives
power to the right and to corporations
and they end up with more influence and
then on top of that we've baked the cake
with all these ingredients I mentioned
and then you put the cherry on top which
is gerrymandering which we've talked
about so extensively over the last few
years you've got to hand it to them this
is a hugely successful to call it a
decade-long
it's longer than a decade
this point this has been hugely
successful the depressed turnout the
people purged who didn't vote we don't
even know how many local and state
elections could have turned out
differently had we not seen these
tactics and techniques work so
effectively and then of course there's
the big ones that are the public
legislative victories that have helped
them when you look at these you realize
it's probably been more like twenty or
thirty years yet Bush v Gore in 2000 the
Republicans successfully stopped a
recount in Florida of the election there
between Al Gore and George Bush which
potentially handed the entire election
to george w bush citizens united in 2010
the republican party opened the
floodgates to spending on campaigns by
rich people and corporations in a way
that was not possible before 2013 shelby
county versus holder this is when the
republican party successfully destroyed
significant parts of the Voting Rights
Act and that has allowed even more voter
suppression now and then this year you
have judges Republican judges in a
variety of different states allowing
gerrymandered election districts to be
used now you might say wait a second
David in some places judges said you
can't use these maps anymore that's
right that that is true but in other
places these horribly biased
gerrymandered maps were actually given
the green light and here is the most
important takeaway from this the
Republican Party realizes that their
policies are unpopular and they're not
good for a lot of people but instead of
saying we should change the platform
they instead say let's prevent
minorities and poor people from voting
okay so what do we do
step one tomorrow you got a vote vote
anyway okay
everybody's got a vote because when half
the country doesn't vote even with all
of this stuff that they've done
everything I listed so far if we can
just increase turnout by fifteen percent
it's over I mean not these things will
not matter
if we can increase turnout by fifteen
percent number two if Democrats win the
house we need to push them to actually
run investigations into these efforts
during the next two years if we don't
vote we are giving up the fight before
it even starts because they want you not
to vote if you say I'm so sick and tired
of the status quo I don't think they
care what I want I am NOT voting you've
just done what they want effectively and
then one last thing on this when the
left points out that democracy is broken
the right loves this dumb talking point
which is the u.s. is a constitutional
republic it's not a democracy they use
that to justify voter suppression okay
the u.s. is technically a representative
republic that's true and it's supposed
to have democratically elected governing
bodies the House and Senate using
different words saying it's not a
democracy at all it's a republic it
doesn't eliminate the fact that you have
a constitutional right to vote do not
fall for it okay I want to hear from you
about this
we cannot be tricked in this way I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter a David Pakman show
quick break back after this today's
program is sponsored in part by fare
indigo dot-com who is giving everybody
in our audience 15% off their first
order only when you use the promo code
Pakman at checkout
I talk all the time about how harmful
the garment industry can be both in
terms of the environment and workers
rights which is why I'm very excited to
tell you about fair
indigo comm which is a clothing company
focused not only on the extreme quality
and longevity of their products but also
actually making sure that the people
making the clothes actually get a fair
and living wage and that every step of
the manufacturing process is
eco-friendly if you're watching on
YouTube right now I'm wearing the
organic pima cotton hoodie which is
extraordinarily comfortable fair
Indigo's clothing is made from preemie
alpaca and ultra-high quality organic
pima cotton the softest and longest
lasting cotton on earth it's grown by
small-scale farmers without any
pesticides and all of the garments are
manufactured at a mill that recycles
100% of its water uses earth-friendly
dyes and everything is cut and sewn by
experts at their Lima Peru workshop
where all workers are actually paid fair
wages go check out everything they have
for both men and women everything from
short and long sleeve t-shirts polo
sweaters hoodies to women's tops dresses
and scarves there's really something for
everybody and these are styles that
don't get old so it's clothing you'll
want to wear for years with quality that
ensures you'll actually be able to click
the link under this video shipping is
always free on orders over $75 and
you'll save 15% when you use the promo
code PA que ma n at checkout